I mean I think we can go on with facts
values distinctions for a long
is not very fruitful but I wanted to go
back to something about European ID
identity and the difficulty of European
identity how to define it it's actually
very difficult to define national
identity now we had you know in British
schools now it's compulsory to teach
British values British values and there
was a committee a very high-powered
educationist philosophers and everything
else and they tried to draw up they
argued for five years about what were
British values and they came down with
three okay
democracy tolerance and the rule of law
now exactly well what I mean is but but
what I mean is they're very very thin
they're probably the values that most
people in the European Union would would
would subscribe to and they only to a
very limited extent define what the
national cultures are about they can't
get agreement on anything anything more
substantial and one of the values that I
thought is very striking missing value
was free speech it's not there and we
would I would have thought that would
have been a fundamental British value
going but it's not there why isn't it
there
because it might cause a fence to a lot
of people now living in Britain so free
speech is there now how does this work
in Europe I don't know whether other
European countries whether it then and
the Netherlands has tried to drop a list
of Dutch values and what I've tried to
draw up a list because Luxembourg is
under attack and the Luxembourg is
identity that's the Luxembourg
the whole business model is under attack
look after Lux leagues and so on so they
are trying to discuss among its very
funny
amongst themselves they're trying to
discuss like what makes a stick we need
to diversify but I love it when you say
about a country because it tells you so
much about the time in which we are
living their whole business model is
they can they cannot agree on what makes
Luxembourg Luxembourg
apart from Texas and you know what they
came up with one word bridge Germany and
France built to redefine a national
identity I had two weeks ago in Vienna a
conversation that a German politician
member of the CDU and he insisted that
we even should give up on national
identities that we should build a Europe
on regional identities he said like the
people in Bavaria the people in
garmisch-partenkirchen have a completely
different identity even if different
language than the same German people
living in Flensburg not far from the
Danish border so we should one second I
think he had to get the Vella point he
said he said in order to to help this to
build this already existing regional
identities that's very good because
region never has an army and
nationalistic feelings in these regions
are mine by definition innocence so why
not I thought this idea was was fairly
interesting I think I'd never believe
that I say that but I'm with this guy
from the CDU because you know
nation-states are such a recent
invention yeah as a friend of my latest
invention would say you know they're
like that person in the Edgar Allan Poe
story who was dead but he doesn't
realize it yet and so he's still walking
around but you know our identities of
course there region of course I am
despite the fact that I'm an atheist I'm
a North German Protestant I can't help
it and I will always be that
and I sort of have a half serious
proposal of redrawing European cultural
boundaries according to what people call
things sold in bakeries because you know
that whether you eat in german-speaking
countries a pollutant or as a mole or a
slipper which are all the same thing
they really mark what people think about
their lives but inner nation-states we
should be regional and European I think
the nation-state is a completely
expendable entity in between we have is
the only thing we have it's not like
it's worth it's worth remembering that
the three largest nations originally
creating the European Union Germany
France and Italy now they're all d
resist nations entirely constructed by
an elite there was the French Revolution
and Napoleon creating France out of a
whole lot of bore bore provinces which
didn't speak French it took something
like fifteen constitutions and 150 years
before that became a convincing
democracy and you've got Massimo des L
you're saying we have created Italy now
we have to create Italians that was 150
years ago and I rest my case
in Germany Bismarck said we don't need
speeches or majority decisions we need
blood and iron and I rest my case again
and these are the elites of those
countries based on those experiences
that have been trying to like you know
strauss-kahn saying we have created
Europe now we must create your
appearance and I don't think this is the
right way to go around I hope there will
be one day something that one can
identify as a European but at the moment
I think you have to start from the
grassroots upwards and the bakery model
is a very good one
you know let's start there let them you
know create and you know why do young
Europeans go off to America or go off to
the next best thing which is land
is because because they feel free they
feel they can do things they feel they
can express themselves you know in
Europe they feel tight they feel they're
over-regulated they feel they're
supposed to be doing things and
overtaxed yes and you know you know I
mean why can't I can't you're 18 you
don't feel that you're over-regulated
and overtaxed oh they do in it's funny
what they do live in London London is
the biggest yes like they do London is
the biggest the fourth biggest French
town why why did they go there well I
mean that's a and also these things are
not rational and it's very interesting
you know got the pole at the moment in
Poland all the politicians are agonizing
over it because you know a couple of
million poles simply decamped to
particularly Britain and and the British
Isles but elsewhere and everybody says
oh it's the money women raised it's got
nine to do with the money you talk to
young poles in England or they just say
you just can't live there you just can't
live back home it's why young Irish
people used to come to England you know
they feel tight they feel that the
atmosphere is is you know that
everything's closing in on them and this
is Europe I think Europe's greatest
problem at the moment the young people
feel there is an atrophied establishment
and I'm afraid that Brussels epitomizes
this and symbolises this and they feel
their whole thing is just sort of run
into the buffers that it's and and and
that it's boring yeah I don't think
you're quite right again I think an
overstatement I mean you've got to
distinguish between minorities and
majorities there always be masses of
people all through history who wanted to
leave their country the immigrations and
everything else but that's not true of
the that's not true of the majority I
mean if all poles felt like this way
there'd be no one in Poland and of
course and for most poles aren't going
to emigrate I mean and most
eighteen-year-old white a lot of young
people do do it because they're always
looking for a better life somewhere else
been true throughout history progress
progress they look at it as a form of
progress in society do you get you know
here we're talking about 10% of the
population saying I can't live in this
country and these are the brightest and
the best that's not quite 50 percent of
people in Britain when asked would they
prefer to lis live somewhere else have
tended to say yes but but any what does
that mean actually the climate is well I
agree